mais logo et bannières sur le parvis de
notre dame c'est l'accueil réservé au
nassau fidèles par les militants de
l'association act up à l'index l'église
et ses prises de position contre l'
usage des préservatifs et
l'homosexualité position criminels
soutien actionne alors au cinq cent
cinquante mille personnes sont déjà
mortes du sida et des millions d'autres
sont séropositifs
faire entendre sa voix à faire passer
mon message coûte que coûte les
militants d'act up
mais dès qu'on soit interrompre le four
de la célébration
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les services de sécurité de notre dame
affaire vient l'expression est rapide et
m'excuse
[Applaudissements]
on a décidé qu'on ne pouvait plus
supporter des positions de l'église un
petit enfer l'épidémie de sida
je crois qu'il faut dire que l'église en
france et une en trace directe à la
prévention
l'église condamne le préservatif alors
que c'est le seul moyen de sauver des
vies à l'époque actuelle
je crois que l'église a une attitude
très discriminatoire envers positif et
les malades s'allumant scandaleux
pendant ce temps là le parce que steven
dans une église encore pu être
tranquille alors que des gens avec la
fougue train alors je m'en fous
complètement
dix militants d'act up for change est
aussi féru oui si l'on distribue
gratuitement des préservatifs
[Musique]